Traductor: Javi Garriz
Revisor: Nerea García Garmendia
¿Cuántos de vosotros
hacéis compras online?
¿Utilizáis banca electrónica?
¿Os dais cuenta de la cantidad
de información personal
que mandamos a la red cuando hacemos eso?
Esta información incluye
vuestros números de cuenta,
dirección postal, fecha de nacimiento...
De ser expuesta a terceros,
esta información podría
darles la posibilidad de atacaros,
robando, haciendo operaciones
no autorizadas en vuestra cuenta,
usurpando vuestra identidad, etc.
¿Qué pasa con los datos médicos?
Cada vez hay más comunidades autónomas
que dejan que los ciudadanos
nos podamos descargar
nuestro historial médico online.
¿Pero qué pasaría si, por ejemplo,
la empresa que os va a contratar
tuviera acceso a vuestro historial médico?
O peor aún, a vuestro ADN.
En el contexto actual de Internet,
con vuestros datos personales
continuamente viajando en la red,
es fundamental que vayan protegidos.
¿Cómo protegemos la información?
Eso se hace mediante el cifrado
o encriptamiento,
que a través de ciertos procesos,
hacemos que esa información
sea ininteligible
-no entendible, no accesible-
para cualquiera ajeno a la información.
Normalmente lo que se hace es
mezclar el texto en claro con una clave
y devuelve el texto cifrado.
Un ejemplo muy sencillo:
imaginad que queréis cifrar este texto.
Una secuencia binaria,
el lenguaje de los computadores.
Vamos a utilizar una clave
y el método, el algoritmo,
es una simple suma binaria bit a bit.
Ahí tendríamos nuestro texto cifrado.
La persona que recibe esa información
tiene que descifrarla, ¿qué hace?
Vuelve a sumar la clave bit a bit,
pero esta vez con el texto cifrado.
Y así volvemos a tener
el texto en claro.
Este cifrado, que es
bastante sencillo de realizar,
si la clave cumple una serie
de condiciones, que son:
que sea tan larga como el mensaje,
puramente aleatoria
y usada solo una vez,
es un cifrado irrompible.
Es 100 % seguro desde
un punto de vista matemático.
Por eso se denomina el "secreto perfecto".
Fue inventado en 1917 por Gilbert Vernam.
Sin embargo, si os dais cuenta,
la persona que cifra y descifra,
necesita poseer de antemano una clave.
Por lo tanto, si dos personas que se
quieren comunicar y mandarse un secreto
tienen que, previamente,
haberse comunicado una clave secreta,
esto parece un círculo vicioso.
Históricamente, ¿cómo se solucionaba?
Se entregaban físicamente
las claves en mano.
El alto mando alemán
en la II Guerra Mundial
distribuía las claves
para la máquina Enigma,
que sabréis que es la clave que utilizaba
el ejercito alemán para comunicarse.
Las distribuía mensualmente,
con todas las claves diarias
que el ejército necesitaría.
Os podéis imaginar que esto conlleva
un gran problema logístico.
Sobre todo en el caso de submarinos
que pasaban largas temporadas
fuera de puerto.
Los bancos en los años 70,
intentaron mandar físicamente las claves
a sus clientes, mediante mensajero seguro,
pero pronto se dieron cuenta de que cuando
el número de clientes empezó a aumentar,
esto era logísticamente imposible.
Imaginaos ahora,
en el contexto de Internet,
en el que los usuarios se cuentan
por miles de millones,
sería un problema inabarcable.
Este problema se conoce como
el "problema de distribución de la clave"
y en los años 70, después de dos mil años
de historia sin haberse resuelto,
había un cierto escepticismo
en la comunidad criptográfica
de que realmente tuviera solución.
Pero gracias a la perseverancia de tres
hombres: Diffie, Hellman y Merkle,
en 1976 se logra lo que se considera
el mayor hito de la criptografía moderna,
y se inventa lo que se conoce
como "criptografía asimétrica".
Esta criptografía utiliza dos claves:
una para cifrar y otra para descifrar,
a diferencia de la que
os he enseñado antes.
La clave cifrado
se denomina "clave pública"
y es accesible a todo el mundo.
La clave privada
solo la tiene una persona,
de manera que si Alice
quiere mandar un mensaje a Bob,
-Alice y Bob se consideran
el emisor y el receptor
de un mensaje en criptografía-
tiene que coger una de sus claves
que está disponible públicamente,
por ejemplo, en un repositorio,
cifra su mensaje, y Bob utiliza
su clave privada para descifrarlo.
Esto se suele ver, simbólicamente,
como un candado para la clave pública
y una llave para la clave privada.
De manera que todos podemos coger
los candados de alguien,
mandar la información secreta,
cerramos candado, lo enviamos,
y solo la persona destinataria
tiene la llave -la clave privada-
para abrir el candado.
¿Cómo se logra esto?
Matemáticamente se hace con funciones
que se denominan "unidireccionales",
quiere decir que son fáciles de hacer
en un sentido -cifrar, cerrar el candado-,
pero son difíciles de invertir
-que sería abrir el candado-,
sin la información de la clave privada,
que es la llave.
Una de estas funciones
es la factorización
de un número en sus factores primos,
y en esta operación se basa
el algoritmo de cifrado simétrico
más utilizado actualmente,
que se denomina RSA.
De manera muy simplificada,
la clave pública es "n"
y es el resultado de multiplicar
dos números primos,
de tal manera que si "n" es lo
suficientemente grande,
encontrar "p" y "q" es muy difícil
para los computadores,
puesto que no hay
una manera fácil de factorizar
va a probar todos los "p" y "q" posibles.
Esto es computacionalmente lento.
Para que os hagáis una idea
de los números "n"
de las claves que se utilizan
actualmente por RSA,
esta sería la longitud del número "n"
para una clave de 2064 bits.
Son 617 cifras decimales.
¿Es seguro RSA?
Actualmente cifra información militar,
comercial, diplomática...
¿Podremos confiar en su seguridad
en el futuro?
Para romper RSA hay que encontrar
"p" y "q" de manera rápida.
Los avances en computación
hacen que se duplique
la capacidad para computar
cada dieciocho meses.
Pero esto no es suficiente,
necesitamos hacerlo mucho más rápido.
Los matemáticos llevaban siglos
intentando encontrar un atajo
para factorizar, sin éxito.
Sin embargo, un matemático
salió de su zona de confort
y miró el problema
desde otro punto de vista.
Aplicó la mecánica cuántica,
y en el año 1994,
Peter Shor encontró el único algoritmo
de factorización capaz de factorizar
en un tiempo polinómico,
en lugar de exponencial.
¿Qué quiere decir eso?
Quiere decir, en esa curva veis el tiempo
que tardaría en factorizar un computador,
respecto a la longitud de la clave.
Si veis la curva que sube,
eso es lo que tarda un computador clásico.
La curva más baja es lo que tarda
un computador cuántico,
de manera que para cualquier número "n",
los tiempos son bastantes diferentes.
Y aún más, si aumenta "n", la diferencia
entre tiempos es mucho mayor.
¿Esto qué implica?
Implica que RSA está rota.
Pero, ¿en qué se basa
el computador cuántico?
Los principios de los que
os he hablado antes, ¿cuáles son?
El primero se llama
"Superposición Cuántica".
Un sistema cuántico es capaz de estar
en múltiples estados simultáneamente.
A diferencia de un bit clásico,
que puede estar en 0 ó en 1,
Un bit cuántico o "qubit",
puede estar en 0 y 1 a la vez.
Esto quiere decir que,
con unos cuantos qubits,
puedes mapear un número
de soluciones posibles
que escala como dos elevado
al número de qubits.
Por lo tanto, puedes probar
muchísimas más combinaciones
que en el caso de un computador clásico.
En este caso, las probabilidades "p" y "q"
que solucionan tu problema.
Por otro lado,
el "Entrelazamiento Cuántico"
es la propiedad que tienen partículas
de "hablarse entre sí",
aunque estén separadas
por una distancia física.
Es como si tuvieran telepatía.
El computador cuántico
utiliza esa propiedad
para que los qubits hablen entre sí
y procesen más eficientemente.
Cuando se publicó el algoritmo
de Shor, en los años 90,
nadie pensaba que se iba a construir
un computador cuántico
y no hubo demasiada preocupación.
Sin embargo, hoy en día,
en los últimos años,
especialmente en los últimos cinco años,
empresas como Google,
IBM, Microsoft, Intel,
están haciendo unos avances enormes
en computación cuántica,
tantos, que instituciones
internacionales como el NIST,
el Instituto Nacional de
Estándares y Tecnologías americano,
ha recomendado a las empresas
y a los centros públicos
que vayan cambiando ya
sus protocolos criptográficos,
a aquellos que sean resistentes
al computador cuántico.
Ellos piensan que llegará
un computador cuántico
capaz de amenazar la seguridad
de la información en unos 10 años.
¿Qué hacemos?
Evidentemente hay que buscar una manera
alternativa de cifrar la información.
Os hablé antes de un secreto perfecto,
el Cifrado de Secreto Perfecto,
pero necesita distribuir
una clave de manera segura.
¿Cómo hacemos que sea segura
ante un computador cuántico?
Quizá buceando en la cuántica,
podamos resolver un problema
que la misma cuántica ha creado.
Y uno de los principios
en el corazón de la mecánica cuántica,
es el principio de incertidumbre
de Heisenberg.
Si lo estudiasteis en el colegio,
este principio nos dice que no es posible
medir dos variables a la vez
en el mundo cuántico, siempre.
Una partícula, como un electrón,
si queremos medir su posición y velocidad,
podemos hacerle incidir una luz
y ver su reflejo.
Pero cuando hacemos esto,
la mínima cantidad de luz
que podemos mandar es un fotón.
Cuando llega al electrón, choca contra él,
como si fuera una bola de billar,
le transfiere energía y entonces
el electrón cambia de velocidad.
Por lo tanto, la misma medida está
cambiando el estado de la medida.
Entonces, existe una incertidumbre aquí.
Esto no solo aplica
a posición y velocidad,
aplica a otras muchas magnitudes.
Una de ellas es la polarización
de fotones individuales.
¿Qué es la polarización?
Es la manera de girar que tiene la luz.
Puede girar en todas las direcciones del
espacio: vertical, horizontal, diagonal...
¡la luz es así! (Ríe)
Entonces, ¿cómo la medimos?
La podemos medir con un polarizador,
que es una lámina, un filtro,
que solo deja pasar
una dirección de polarización.
Si ahora tenemos un fotón,
verticalmente polarizado,
que incide sobre un polarizador diagonal,
que está a 45 grados,
esto forma un principio
de incertidumbre también,
de manera que el fotón
lo que puede hacer es,
en un 50 % de probabilidad
se va a absorber
y en otro 50 % de probabilidad va a pasar,
pero va a cambiar su polarización.
Es en este cambio, en el que se basaron
Charles Bennett y Gilles Brassard,
entonces en IBM, en el año 1984,
para formular el "Principio
de Distribución de Clave Cuántica BB84".
Y sin entrar en muchos detalles,
os diré que el protocolo se basa
en la transmisión de fotones individuales
con esos estados de polarización,
que tiene Alice, y Bob va a ir
midiendo en dos bases, en dos canales,
de tal manera que son capaces de compartir
una secuencia binaria sin errores.
A menos que haya habido
un espía en el canal.
Porque el espía va a generar un error,
y va a cambiar ciertos estados
de 1 a 0 y viceversa,
y entonces Alice y Bob
podrán detectarlo.
Es la primera vez que se logra
distribuir una clave
en la que la seguridad se puede verificar.
De tal manera que si no ha sido seguro
el protocolo de distribución de clave,
esa clave se desecha
y se empieza de nuevo.
Esta seguridad es absoluta en términos
de la seguridad de la información.
No depende de la capacidad computacional
de un computador cuántico,
porque se basa en los mismos
principios de la física cuántica.
Y ahora, con esa clave
que tenemos, ¿qué hacemos?
La metemos en el cifrado
que os conté al principio,
que necesitaba una clave
segura y aleatoria.
Ya la tenemos.
Podríamos decir que es el secreto perfecto
y resistente al computador cuántico.
También podemos mandar partículas
entrelazadas para distribuir una clave,
de modo que las partículas entrelazadas
viajan en superposición
de dos estados de polarización.
Es como si tiráramos dos monedas girando
a dos extremos del mundo,
una en Nueva York,
cuando la mides, cae en cara,
y eso hace que la que está en Tokio,
sin haberla tocado,
cambie y se ponga en cruz.
Están definidas siempre
con sentidos opuestos,
y hay una correlación entre ellas
que no se sabe explicar, pero es así.
Esta propiedad
se puede utilizar de tal manera
que en vez de cara, digamos,
la polarización sería horizontal,
con lo que podemos codificar
el estado 0 y Bob tendría el 1.
Siguen tirando la moneda
y aparece el estado vertical,
que codifica el 1,
y por tanto Bob tiene un 0.
Y así van repitiendo.
Al final de la transmisión Bob cambia
sus 1 por 0 y sus 0 por 1,
y ya han compartido una secuencia.
¿Cuál es el estado de esta
tecnología actualmente?
La Distribución Cuántica de Clave
necesita fotones individuales
que se pueden lograr atenuando un láser
y detectar esos fotones
de manera individual,
hay también detectores
comerciales que logran esto.
Se ha probado en enlaces de fibra óptica,
en enlaces aéreos...
Pero se enfrenta
a ciertos retos tecnológicos:
Al ser una señal tan atenuada,
los fotones individuales son
vulnerables al ruido y a la absorción.
Aún así, se ha logrado en el año 2017
la transmisión de una clave cuántica
desde un satélite a dos puntos
de la Tierra a 1.200 km.
Esto lo ha logrado China.
Por otro lado, la UE acaba de firmar
un acuerdo en el que varios países,
entre ellos España, se comprometen
a instalar una infraestructura
que conecte a varias ciudades europeas
con distribución cuántica de clave,
tanto por fibra óptica
como en espacio libre,
para proteger a Europa,
a nuestra economía, de ciberamenazas.
Y por último, os voy dejar
una idea más futurista,
pero que ya hay muchos laboratorios
que están trabajando en ella:
se llama "Internet Cuántico".
Sería una red en la que los nodos
serían computadores cuánticos.
Y se intercambiarían información
mediante canales ultra seguros
que proporcionaría
la Distribución Cuántica de Clave.
Este Internet no va a sustituir al actual,
no necesitamos un Internet Cuántico
para mirar nuestras redes sociales.
Pero sí sería una herramienta
que podría permitir la distribución
segura de información muy sensible,
como secretos de seguridad nacional,
información de los usuarios muy privada,
como datos del genoma, etc.
Lo que sí está claro es que estamos
viviendo un cambio de paradigma,
en el que no solo las comunicaciones
y la computación están cambiando,
sino otros campos, como los sensores,
la simulación cuántica...
Esto nos permite, por ejemplo,
simular la realidad a nivel molecular,
lo que nos va a permitir
desarrollar nuevos medicamentos,
nuevos tratamientos médicos
más eficientes,
simular el clima de manera más eficiente.
Y todos estos avances se enmarcan
dentro de lo que ya se llama
la "Segunda Revolución Cuántica".
¿Estáis preparados?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)